hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in notes from
underground Fyodor Dostoevsky has his
narrator and intellectual and st.
Petersburg talked quite a bit about
different kinds of pleasures and some of
these would be wholesome pleasures the
sorts of things that all of us may
partake in you know the sweetness of an
apple the enjoyment of light
conversation at a party
the you know nice look of a new tie or
anything along those lines
he actually doesn't dwell on those very
much because in this work he's
interested in digging into the pleasures
that are less savory the pleasures that
we may view as in some way perverse or
morbid and he talks about you know
strong people with strong nerves who
can't understand the somewhat more
subtle aspects of pleasure that is
they're able to enjoy the good healthy
pleasures but they're not able to see
the other things that people delight in
and if you think about this for a minute
why is it important to actually
understand the full range of pleasure
well if you want to understand why human
beings do the things that they do and if
they're you know desires for pleasure
role in that and their pleasures are not
exactly the same thing that you find
pleasant it might be useful to actually
know what people do in fact desire and
enjoy even if it's not the sort of thing
that you consider to be good or healthy
or noble so he talks quite a bit about a
number of different kinds of pleasures
you know some are perfectly fine going
out on a spring day and enjoying the air
bending down to pick some hyacinths or
crocuses or lilies or whatever it
happens to be enjoying the sound of rain
falling on the windows above all of
those you know cuddling up with a kitten
or a puppy
you know caressing a loved one all of
those are quite good right but those
aren't the full range of things that we
actually do enjoy Dostoevsky says and
here it's interesting he's got this
strong contrast running throughout the
entire thing between the ordinary person
of action and the intellectual but here
he all the way there are some pleasures
that he attributes to the intellectual
he doesn't say that the ordinary people
don't also indulge in some of these so
these are the non wholesome pleasures
one of these is causing other people to
suffer he mentions how Cleopatra is
reputed to have shoved these pins golden
pins you know so a luxury item through
the breasts of her slaves just to cause
them pleasure no it's cause them pain to
cause herself pleasure and he says you
know people do that sort of thing out of
boredom and you might think of all the
different sort of sadistic actions that
people from children all the way up to
the age have done in order to make
themselves feel alive for a moment by
inflicting some suffering on somebody
else usually somebody who they have
control over somebody who they can pay
somebody who they can compel in
when somebody who has to take it that is
a kind of pleasure he also talks about
the intellectual who is groaning with a
toothache there's this incredibly funny
passage in here where he's talking about
how after the third or fourth day
they're not groaning the same way as say
a peasant was would be he says here we
go the moans that they're feeling
expressed a whole bunch of things he
says listen I'm the second or third day
of pain when he's no longer moaning the
way he did on the first day simply
because his toothache
he's been affected by education and by
European civilization he moans like a
man who as they say nowadays has been
uprooted from the soil and lost contact
with the people his moans soon becomes
strident and perverse and they continued
day and night he certainly knows he's
not helping himself by moaning like that
no one knows better than he that he's
tormenting and and irritating himself
and others for nothing that his audience
and this includes his family for whom
he's trying so hard is listening to him
with disgust
they don't believe he's sincere in the
least and realized he could moan
differently more simply with all these
trills and flourishes and that he's
putting it all on out of sheer spite and
viciousness now a little bit after that
he says there's voluptuous pleasure and
all this degradation and the realization
of it but some of that pleasure comes
from imposing that on everybody around
you the groans the you know endless
suffering that there you're making them
deal with why not just close the door
and or tell them to go on vacation or
something like that and another instance
of this would be the underground man's
insistence with this officer that he you
know have his saber down the right way
and he finally imposes his will on that
that impertinent officer who keeps
coming to him he's a petty
bureaucrat who's acting like a jerk to
this this military officer because he
can and so that's one type of pleasure
causing other people suffering or pain
another thing that that Dostoevsky has
the underground man talk about is doing
things that are bad knowing that they're
bad things that cannot be undone things
that are based things that are as we
would say today nasty or disgusting and
he talks about this and he says to begin
with he says I was conscious of things
that are very wholesome the beautiful
and the good right
and he says IIIi knew about these things
and then I did ugly things things that
everyone does probably but I did
precisely at moments when I was most
aware that they shouldn't be done
he doesn't say what these are but we
could well imagine and he says the more
conscious I was of the good and the
beautiful
the deeper I sank into the mud and the
more likely I was to remain mired in it
now did he simply have a negative
reaction saying oh I'm such a bad guy
this really sucks I feel pain because I
look at myself and how degraded I am no
he took pleasure in it
and I think many people in fact do it
Dostoevsky is onto something quite
important here he says first I went
through this inner struggle I was
ashamed I you know tried to stop doing
these things and then I started to reach
a point where I felt a secret unhealthy
base little pleasure in to creeping back
into my hole after some disgusting night
in Petersburg and forcing myself to
think I'd again done something filthy
that what I had done couldn't be undone
and I inwardly know out at myself for it
tore at myself ate myself away so he's
feeling remorse he's feeling these
negative emotions and then he says then
something happened the bitterness
transformed into a shameful accurse in
sweetness and finally into a great
unquestionable
yes yes definitely a pleasure I mean it
and he says that's why I started out on
the subject I wanted to find out whether
others experienced this kind of pleasure
too and then he says I'll explain it to
you I derived pleasure precisely from
the blinding realization of my
degradation I realized that there was
something wrong with me and at first I
felt bad about that and I still do feel
bad about it but precisely in the
feeling bad I get to feel good there's a
compensation a pleasure voluptuousness
within that so doing bad things becoming
bad becoming a person who does these bad
things these base things over and over
again the degradation as he talks about
it that can produce a pleasure in quite
a few people they they delight in being
called the degenerate gambler or they
you know find a way to turn their
addiction into something cool or you
know we might go on and on and on
another thing he talks about as
providing a certain kind of perverse
pleasure on the part of the intellectual
in this case is despair at the
hopelessness of the situation that he
finds himself in if he can't really be
anything he can't actually deal with
life the way that ordinary people do
everything that he looks at every path
in front of him it makes sense but it
also you know in a way has all sorts of
holes in it and doesn't make sense in
certain ways and he can't really commit
to anything everywhere he looks there's
some sort of problem that can make you
feel hopeless that can cause you to feel
despair and Dostoevsky
through his character tells us well
there's a certain pleasure even in that
perhaps this is the pleasure that leads
us when we are in a losing situation and
there's nothing that we can do about it
that leads us to laugh some people
that is a kind of hysteria if we're
thinking in terms of the underground man
an alternative explanation is possible
that it is either an expression of or it
is a means to taking some sort of
pleasure in the face of hopelessness
finally he also talks about suffering
itself and he talks about the toothache
and and he says you know I can enjoy it
good to think you know and people are
like how can you actually do that well
he says there is pleasure in a toothache
once I suffered a toothache for a whole
month I can tell you there's pleasure in
it people don't rage in silence they
moaned they're not ordinary moans
they're malicious and in this moaning
you express the pleasure of the sufferer
if you didn't enjoy it you wouldn't moan
you would silently suffer it the moaning
itself could be an expression of a kind
of pleasure now I think a lot of people
would hear that and say you're nuts
I don't moan or a groan or gasp or
whatever it happens to be because I'm
feeling pleasure I feel pain but with
time and for some people it can become
its own kind of pleasure and there are
people by the way who do this with just
the physical pain itself there there are
cases of people who and we're not just
talking about masochism in the sense of
enjoying being humiliated by somebody
else or even having pain inflicted upon
oneself but they have something going on
with their body and this is why we often
talk about this as morbid they begin to
feel a kind of pain in it by the way
this is not a realization unique to
Dostoevsky somebody else who talked
about this back in the ancient world
Epicurus believe it or not although it's
it's just one passage then the last
thing that he talks about is this this
cycle this dynamic of what he calls
humiliation
leading to punishment and then feeling a
sense of remorse and repentance but
knowing that he doesn't really feel it
and he's not going to follow through on
it and he's not going to become a better
person in the the end he talks about
this here we go
he says that how can one have the
slightest respect for a man who tries to
find pleasure in the feeling of
humiliation itself I'm not saying that
out of any market sense of repentance in
general I couldn't stand saying sorry
papa I'll never do it again
but it wasn't because I wasn't capable
of saying it on the contrary I was too
prone to say it and you should have seen
under what circumstances - I'd get
myself blamed almost purposely for
something with which I had nothing to do
even in thought or dream that was the
most disgusting but even so I was always
deeply moved I repented my wickedness
and I cried in this of course I was
deceiving myself though I never did so
deliberately and then he says if you ask
me now why tortured and tormented myself
like that I'll tell you I was bored just
sitting with my arms folded so I went in
for all those tricks believe me it's
true just watch yourself carefully
you'll understand that's the way it
works I made up whole stories about
myself and put myself through all sorts
of adventures to satisfy at any price my
need to live how many times did I
convince myself I was offended just like
that for no reason at all and I knew I
had nothing to be offended about I law I
was strongly tempted to play tricks of
this sort that in the end I lost all
restraint he puts himself into these
imaginary dynamics as if life isn't
already hard enough and doesn't give us
enough trouble he gets himself into
trouble but it allows him to take a
certain secret delight so if we actually
want to understand human nature if we
want to deal with human beings as they
are and understand ourselves we need to
recognize that people do in fact take
pleasure in all sorts of things that are
quite unwholesome quite unhealthy bad
base but they do that and that is
perhaps part of the nature of this crazy
complex thing that we call humanity
you